o Olá bem-vindos também falar Diego sim
nos dias que todos cometemos e tive
cometemos de forma absolutamente
inconsciente e como temos cada vez mais
porque a tecnologia faz cada vez mais
parte da nossa vida e dificulta cada vez
mais a forma como nos comunicamos é cada
vez mais comum nós considerarmos que
estamos a comunicar mais e melhor mas na
verdade cada vez comunicamos mesmo menos
e esse é um dos problemas também na
educação Eu Sou professora Mas Sou
professora Universitária e enquanto
estava ao vivo estava a pensar que é
curioso como todas essas problemáticas e
todos os questionamentos em relação à
educação terminam no ensino secundário
questiona-se muito pouco a metodologia
do ensino universitário a pensa-se muito
pouco sobre como é o ensino nas
universidades ou como poderia ser
a questão que me persegue também há
muitos anos e persegue-me porque eu sou
professora Universitária por mero acaso
aconteceu na minha vida agarrei a
oportunidade vestir a camisola e percebi
que de facto Adoro ensinar não adoro
toda a componente burocrática toda a
componente administrativa a componente
até avaliativa que está associada ao
ensino mas gosto de verdadeiramente de
passar a palavra gosto verdadeiramente
de sentir que as pessoas que estão a
lidar comigo sai um bocadinho melhores
que aprendem alguma coisa que se
valorizam e sobretudo que se automotiva
vão aprender em todos os dias e é sobre
isso que eu hoje vos bem falar vamos
falar sobre a nossa relação com a
internet EA forma como estamos
continuamente a cometer erros em relação
a nossa relação com a internet mas por
isso nós precisamos de recuar uns anos
no tempo
e colocar a 1981/1981 eu fui para a
escola e quando comecei a ir para a
escola comecei a levantar mais cedo e
foi então que tive o meu primeiro
contacto com a tecnologia mais
importante da minha vida é a rádio o meu
pai tinha por hábito acordar ir para a
casa de banho tomar o seu vamos fazer o
seu sua higiene e ligava sempre um
pequeno transistor Sabe aqueles
transistor espanhol Asus aqueles que
apanham com algum ruído as várias as
várias sintonia C portanto eu acordei
durante muitos anos da minha vida
ouvindo ao longe aquele som fanhoso das
notícias na rádio depois quando ia para
a cozinha já ouvia um outro rádio com
melhor qualidade mas ainda assim como a
qualidade possível para 1981 que não tem
comparação com Digamos que o sistema
wi-fi que nós temos inclusivamente nos
computadores ou nos telemóveis e na
cozinha estava a minha mãe já que o
rádio o
bom e com uma a estação de rádio
diferente é curioso que os meus pais
sempre se entenderam muito bem em
relação à as rádios que as estações de
rádio que eu viam mas tinham diferentes
o meu pai queria ouvir notícias a minha
mãe queria ouvir notícias e música e era
neste neste ambiente radiofónico que eu
acordava e que eu dava início ao
meio-dia depois ia para a escola e
quando voltava a minha mãe trabalhava em
casa quando voltava eu continuava a
ouvir rádio e continuava a ouvir rádio e
cresci a ouvir os perder antes de Lisboa
o jogo da mala na Rádio Renascença e
muitos outros a bola branca também na
Rádio Renascença e muitos outros
programas de rádio aqui ainda hoje fazem
parte do meu Imaginário e provavelmente
dos que estão aqui nesta sala também e
então ao longo da vida a rádio esteve
sempre presente foi Aliás a rádio que
abriu todas as portas para mim do ponto
de vista o profissional até o dia de
hoje
bom e depois na adolescência lembro-me
de ter dito as minhas amigas
e daqui algum tempo sou eu que estou
apresentar este programa nós todos
ouvimos um programa de rádio numa numa
rádio local durante a tarde e eu compre
isso esse meu desejo uns anos depois não
fui apresentar aquele programa que já
não existia mas nos anos depois já
durante a faculdade bate à porta daquela
rádio e perguntei posso juntar uma vocês
posso aprender com vocês posso fazer
parte da vossa equipa e aceitaram não
sei bem como é que aconteceu aceitaram e
comecei foi esta a minha Experiência
primeira experiência profissional foi de
fato numa rádio local onde aprendi muito
do que ainda hoje Sai espírito de equipa
Sobretudo o famoso desenrascanço
português também aprende ele
e mais tarde foi a rádio novamente que
me abriu as portas para um outro desafio
profissional desta vez numa escola numa
escola secundária e foi ensinar Tic
técnicas e tecnologias de informação e
comunicação E por que que me aceitaram
não foi pelo meu vasto conhecimento em
informática os garantes foi pela rádio
porque porque aquela escola queria
montar uma rádio escola e acharam que o
meu conhecimento de informática seria
Subsurf ciente para ensinar aos alunos
como se formação documentos no Word como
se trabalha no Excel e se fazem
apresentações PowerPoint que basicamente
era isso que eu ensinada mas sobretudo
queriam explorar o lado radiofónico do
meu do meu currículo para montar uma
rádio escola e foi o que aconteceu e
isto aconteceu por um mero acaso eu vi
um anúncio com curry e fiquei e foi
assim que me transformais daí passei
para a universidade novamente porque
perguntou vocês o que que ele leva a
tornar-se professora Universitária
E foi rápido porque porque cria um
montar uma Rádio Universitária e essa
Rádio Universitária já estava aprovada
Rádio Universidade do Algarve estive
durante cinco anos da minha vida a dar
aulas na Universidade do Algarve tenho
excelentes memórias desse tempo mas qual
foi o problema eu não sabia ser
professora eu não fazia ideia de como
poderia ensinar as matérias eram
complexas era matérias teóricas eu não
estava ensinar o Word o Excel ou
PowerPoint não estava ensinar a formatar
documentos Era bastante mais complexo eu
não tinha missões de pedagogia eu não
tínhamos hoje do que fazer perante um
grupo de alunos estão heterogêneo e foi
aí que eu andei para trás não não
utilizei a internet para procurar como
ensinar eu comecei a pensar em toda a
minha experiência de aluna e a pensar em
tudo o que eu não queria pedir e foi
esse o meu método foi assim que eu
cresci
e eu sinto que tem sido sempre uma
professora diferente das outras ou dos
outros no geral porque eu nunca pensei
naquilo que é preciso fazer naquilo que
eu devo fazer mas naquilo que eu sinto
que os alunos precisam que eu faça e
agora a distância Eu percebo que tive de
facto um período da minha vida em que
fui verdadeiramente o professor
universitário e na verdadeira acepção da
palavra muito pouco preocupada com os
alunos muito focada naquilo que tinha
para ensinar formosura da minha vida em
que o coordenava diferentes
responsabilidades profissionais
diferentes cargos na universidade e fora
dela foi um período muito exigente a
minha vida em que o agora a distância o
olho e não era eu que ele estava era um
automático estava a transmitir matéria e
para me ensinar não é isso e depois
desse período mudei radicalmente a minha
forma de dar as aulas as minhas aulas
são muito focadas naquilo que os alunos
precisam de aprender independentemente
o hiper para algum tempo a motivá-los e
inspirá-los a fazê-los pensar fora da
caixa é encontrar soluções alternativas
para dar a mesma matéria de sempre
porque porque desde o início que eu
ensino rádio desde o início que eu
ensino meios Multimédia desde o ensinio
do início que eu ensino técnicas de
comunicação Multimédia e o grande
segredo de estudo não é ensinar as
técnicas mas sim obrigá-los a pensar
sobre as técnicas e sobretudo obrigá-los
a pensar naquilo que tem para comunicar
porque efetivamente em tudo na nossa
vida é comunicação está subjacente e o
grande problema da nossa vida é a falta
de comunicação Então vamos ver os
principais erros que nós cometemos na
internet sendo que o primeiro
esquecermos das características da
própria internet e ponto de vista do
ponto de vista técnico a internet é uma
estrutura física é uma ligação de cabos
estão
e por baixo do do nosso oceano e que
basicamente alguém desligar um botão de
algum lado é bem provável que deixamos
ter sucesso acesso à rede mas
conceitualmente a internet é um mundo
baseado numa lógica de partilha é
baseado em uma loja de lógica de
autoconstrução de retroação é no fundo a
maior ferramenta de comunicação a qual
alguma vez tivemos acesso mas para Além
disso nós também temos que pensar na
internet no seu lado mais positivo e
mais negativo nós não nos podemos
esquecer que não existem almoços grátis
efetivamente na internet não existem
alguns gráficos aquilo que nós temos de
nunca me esquecer e eu vi isso acontecer
agora com o pandemia as escolas adotarem
ferramentas
e as quais todos temos acesso que fazem
parte do Google tem daqui não tem alguma
ferramenta Google instalado no seu
computador ou no seu ou no seu
Smartphone efetivamente a recorrer a
estas ferramentas que são gratuitas são
convenientes mas sobre os quais nós não
refletirmos em relação ao Impacto que
tem nas nossas vidas quais é que foram
os dados que foram extraídos do Google
Maps foi usado em cada sala de aula
quais os dados foram extraídos da
informação que foi partilhada no Google
classroom por cada professor e cada loja
e este é um dos nossos seus Nós
esquecemos desta característica da
internet acende na partilha e pensamos
apenas no lado bom da partilha que
estamos a partilhar coisas uns com os
outros Mas as coisas que nós partilhamos
uns com os outros também são partilhados
com os Big five já lá vamos
e o outro erro também muito comum é
recusar recusar liminarmente a nossa
pegada digital Não esquecemos que tudo
que está na internet fica na internet
conhece a expressão arrepende Vegas
stays in Vegas pois bem o que fica na
internet espalha-se por aí o que
acontece em Vegas já não fica apenas em
Vegas fica espalhado pela internet e a
cada vez mais difícil Quanto Mais o
Tempo avança quanto a mais anos estamos
na internet é cada vez mais difícil
rastrear a nossa presença no fundo
encontrar o início da nossa pegada e
apagar aquilo que nos interessa pensem
os vossos filhos e na pegada de gigante
que eles vão ter Quando chegarem a vossa
idade porque você já contribuíram para
essa pegada quando partilhar um
fotografias deles enquanto eram crianças
nós temos de pensar na questão da pegada
e pensar sempre no keek
e deixar na internet está acessível a
todos em todo o mundo e sim é possível
retirar as fotografias do Instagram e
sim é possível manipular os vídeos do
Tik Tok e sim é possível fazer o quê nós
quisermos os textos que nós deixamos na
internet inclusivamente com a voz já
existem ferramentas de Inteligência
Artificial que permitem manipular os
vídeos e fazer com que a pessoa que está
a falar no vídeo diga uma coisa
completamente diferente Este é um dos
erros é deixar as coisas à Solta
colocá-las na internet sem pensar eu
quero que o meu patrão Veja isto eu
quero que daqui a 20 anos alguém
encontre esta informação sobre mim temos
todos refletir sobre isso eu contra mim
falo porque há dez anos eu não pensava
sobre isto há cinco anos eu comecei a
pensar sobre isto hoje eu tenho mais
mais cuidado do que tinha mas ainda
assim eu deixo as coisas circular Não
sou melhor do que ninguém mas quero
alertar os por isto porque
é mais aberta estou cada vez mais
consciente do impacto que internet de
facto tem na nossa vida para o bem e
para o mal
nós não podemos também reagir resignar
luz a resignação é um erro um erro
enorme em relação ao digital nós temos
uma uma certa tendência para nos
esquecermos da forma como os mais novos
comunicam por nós éramos crianças ou
adolescentes
os nossos nossos pais falávamos a mesma
língua embora não falássemos exatamente
a mesma linguagem tínhamos as nossas
expressões temos uma espécie de dialeto
e os mais velhos não entendiam o grande
problema hoje é que não só os Miúdos não
falam a mesma língua do que nós muito
menos nós compreendemos a linguagem da
língua que eles falam e eu falo do
digital vamos fazer aqui um teste rápido
quem é que aqui tem Facebook e o utiliza
conta ativa do Facebook o
é muito bem e no Instagram
bom e no Snapchat
E aí
E aí no Tik Tok
Ah pois é
e conseguiram perceber a diferença
É só três pessoas têm conta no Tik Tok
Eu também da ação cinco por quê que
vocês não tem conta no Tik Tok
e não precisam de responder a sua
resposta não entendem a linguagem
os preços perder tempo uma perca de
tempo estar a olhar para aquilo e é
verdade está tudo certo o problema é que
se vocês não entenderem o que se passa
no Tik Tok no Snapchat não consegue
entender os vossos filhos isso não
entenderem os vossos filhos como é que
vão comunicar com eles o mesmo se passa
em sala de aula novamente outro erro
usar viver sem respeitar a etiqueta
digital usar reproduzir os nossos erros
de etiqueta do dia a dia no digital é
mais grave do que parece porque
representa Exatamente isto que não
estamos disponíveis para aprenderes e
nós precisamos de estar todos os dias
todos os dias da nossa vida aprender
porque porque estas ferramentas evolui
mais depressa do que nós estas
ferramentas estão numa constante
evolução e nós não estamos acompanhar
isso nós não estamos acompanhar Nós não
entendemos o que está
e não entendemos o que está a passar não
conseguimos utilizar estas ferramentas
em nosso benefício eu gosto muito de uma
ideia que é compreender a usar por não
ser usado e na verdade na maior parte
dos casos o que a tecnologia está a
fazer é usar luz nós brigamos a
tecnologia nós estamos dependentes da
tecnologia pela sua conveniência pelos
ubiquidade E isto é preocupante e hoje
não venho aqui ensinar nada vem só
pedir-vos que pensem que pensem nesta
última frase que é sacralizar o que a
rede oferece Sem questionar quando nós
fazemos uma pesquisa no Google podem ser
sapatos vermelhos Onde comprar nos
questionamos as respostas
e nós questionamos aquilo que me está a
ser apresentado por nós estamos a
navegar no Instagram nós questionamos a
razão pela qual a sequência de
fotografias é aquela
e como nós estamos no Facebook olhamos e
questionamos se calhar no Facebook
estivemos mais porque porque temos mais
Alerta tem Aparecido Dantas notícias
tantas notícias sobre o que se passa
para o algoritmo do Facebook que é
natural que estejam um pouco mais Alerta
uma chuva o Instagram nem por isso sobre
o Tik Tok muito menos
e portanto importante questionar é
importante olhar com o espírito muito
crítico para todas estas ferramentas e
todos os conteúdos que estas ferramentas
nos oferecem porque em boa verdade nós
neste momento estamos numa Total
dependência de cinco grandes empresas de
comunicação são sobretudo 5 empresas de
tecnologia a álcool a Microsoft a Amazon
o Facebook estão a dominar completamente
o contexto tecnológico no qual nos
movemos e sem pensarmos nos objetivos
estão subjacentes à sua atividade Vamos
ficar esmagados pela tecnologia vergadas
ao ecrã vamos passar parte da nossa vida
olhar assim sem saber exatamente o que
estamos a ver obrigada